on SNL last Saturday comic Pete Davidson
apologized to congressman elect Dan
Crenshaw for mocking his war wound I
made I made a joke about Lieutenant
Commander Dan Crenshaw dan dan Crenshaw
and on behalf of the show and myself I
apologize it was a poor choice of words
the man is a war hero and he deserves
all the respect in the world now in case
you forgot this is what Davidson had
said initially about Crenshaw last week
you may be surprised to hear he's a
congressional candidate from Texas and
not a hit man in a porno movie now you
know you need to remember that Crenshaw
hadn't actually demanded an apology in
fact he tapped the brakes on the always
reving outrage machine I want us to get
away from this culture where we demand
apologies every time someone misspeaks I
think that would be very healthy for our
nation to go in that direction well you
know we don't need to be we don't need
to be outwardly outraged I don't need to
demand apologies from that but SNL knew
what it had to do to quell a PR
nightmare and that is man up I'm sorry
Thank You Pete I appreciate you saying
that so we good we're good apology
accepted
[Applause]
this is Pete Davidson he looks like if
the meth from Breaking Bad was a person
face to face so rare these days when we
hide behind firewalls and lawyers but
SNL went further giving crenshaw the
space to speak at length about veterans
and unity Americans can forgive one
another we can remember what brings us
together as a country and still see the
good in each other this is Veterans Day
weekend which means that it's a good
time for every American to connect with
a veteran tell a veteran never forget
when you say never forget to a veteran
you are implying that as an American you
are in it with them and never forget
those we lost on 9/11 heroes like Pete's
father
so I'll just say Pete never forget never
forget
well that's legitimately awesome so
there were three winners here Crenshaw
for his reasonable response to a
careless comic SNL for finding a clever
way to clean up a mess in America for
being handed and honest-to-god blueprint
for dealing with future outrages instead
of ramping up the rage it dialed it back
we've said it here before it's beyond
time to stop chasing scalps demanding
apologies only to then refuse them
haven't we had enough of the mob the
constant indignation the judgmental
hordes of bored souls spoiling for a
fight I know I have so hear Crenshaw
initiated the new way forward express
your opinion don't condemn and see what
happens
SNL responded with humble good humor and
it's all good and dare I say human
finally a skit worth repeating so I
thought dana day was perfectly executed
on both sides yes and they kept it a
secret so everyone was surprised so that
helped you know to keep it that way
I find Dan Crenshaw quite refreshing I
remember when he was in a nine-person
primary yes there was an open seat in
Houston and he was trying to get
attention and there was a woman that was
running on the Republican side she was
very very wealthy and spending all sorts
of money he didn't have any money to run
and so what he decided to do was to
actually run his district one
miles $25 for four days and tried to get
attention that way
and I think what's happened is that
Houston has found itself a great new
leader they have this congressman who
okay look the pop culture it's not gonna
be nice to him forever right true but so
you just take this moment but it was a
really good lesson about leadership I
also appreciated the suggestion for what
to say to a soldier
rather than thank you for your service
to say never forget I like that
no that's very good one I think this
needs to be reposted every time there's
a new outrage like every week somebody's
already pissed off about something this
is kind of how you solved the problem
yeah you know so to me this was so
classic and so good I just agreed with
you I just can't get over Crenshaw's I'm
sorry that just happened with Greg
I thought the dancringe I was super
classy and I thought he was classy from
the start don't mistake me because I
thought when he said I don't I don't
need an apology right no people say
silly stuff all the time and I think it
was really you know above and beyond for
him to actually come to New York and go
on the show and go through the whole
thing I just thought it was terrific and
what's interesting to me about Crenshaw
is he's not your prototypical politician
he's a guy who's a Republican but he's
been highly critical of President Trump
for example and it strikes me that we
need more people like this in public
office mm-hmm is it well veteran
especially Laura especially on Veterans
Day yeah I think there's a class of 12
or something veterans coming in this
time but we're seeing more veterans and
also more female veterans and I think
that's a good thing yeah in fact there's
a pack right now Nicole that promotes
veterans running because guess what
veterans know each other in moments of
real yeah as Americans they know reality
we have a Republican or no yeah I
thought it was a good moment I thought
it was something that the country can
embrace or huh you know behind I just
didn't think it was necessary me
personally just because I think that so
often people on the right on the
receiving end of this yes and the tone
that normally is said is that fire that
person get rid of and you say one thing
and destroys your career and
I don't want to get in these constant
apology tours I mean I've seen it on the
college campuses we're at the Leadership
Institute campus forum where they just
the mob will take over over something so
simple that could have been handled
behind closed doors so good gesture very
polite cool to see I'm just not in big
of a celebration of you you you think
that this is like like a more of an
isolated incident it's an isolated it
quite frankly if I'm honest it was
forced it was forced the executives
caught him saying look you've ticked off
the veterans all right
you got to do something to make this
right if it wasn't about that then they
would have needed behind closed doors
interesting point it wasn't a
teleprompter so it's not like it was
just a slip of the tongue yeah doc you
know I'll be I really loved what I've
seen in congressman-elect and Crenshaw I
loved the way he handled it from day
number one and not demanding an apology
I think it's great that he actually went
on SNL and he had a little fun with it
it shows his personality I'm really
excited to see what he's gonna do in the
office I think Pete Davidson's apology
was mediocre at best you know I wish we
didn't even get to a point where there's
an apology I agree I don't necessarily
know if we needed one I can't believe
that the comment came out of his mouth
his father died in 9/11 when he was a
young boy and Dan Crenshaw lost his eye
on his third combat tour in Afghanistan
a year after 9/11 he's gonna mock him
for that I mean I don't understand where
the thought processes and that as you
said it was not off-the-cuff this was a
written statement so that was coming and
I just I still just can't wrap my head
around the fact that they thought that
that was okay I I will go back to my
defense you know even though I said it
was a lousy joke that for for some types
of humor the humor is and the fact that
it's awful that you're saying something
that is so objectionable it can't be
real if it came from any place other
than SNL who makes a mockery of look-ins
every week of course maybe I would see a
little bit of humor in it as long and
Crenshaw did as well and wasn't offended
but they make a mockery of Republicans
so they were making a mockery specific
of him is there anybody else in American
life we regularly ma
[Music]